good evening everybody and welcome to
this meeting um I have received
apologies from councelor hori councelor
Hurst councelor Aton and Pamela Warton
um I'm not aware of any other
apologies no thanks Harry um are there
any Declarations of Interest in any
items on the agenda okay before we move
on to the next item um there's quite a
few faces here that are new to me so if
people wouldn't mind can we just go
around and give some introductions so
um forgot who I was
then I'm Denise Weston um I'm a broad
Heath Ward counselor and I chair the
commit yeah hi my name is um D for
hi I'm councelor Paul
[Music]
for the
team hi I'm Sarah but is the head of
Education places and
access hi evening everybody and my name
is zoie Sweeney and I'm the head of
early years and family
help good evening everyone Karen samples
Director of Education for
Trafford evening everybody I'm Jill
McGregor I'm the corporate director for
children's services and I have the DCS
role here in
Trafford hello I'm councelor Karina
Carter um labor counselor for dve Hume
and I'm also the executive member for
children young
people hello I'm Tracy stains I'm head
of service for
theable service very bad
feedback
[Music]
hi Kate shefwood Public Health
consultant in the public health Team and
my colleague uh Helen Goins director of
Public Health be joining us imminently
thanks
Council that Beacon s
Central councelor Joan benett
salmore councelor Eve Park of sale
Central i Owen Sutton councelor for ha
Ward councelor Shan NIS templey
Central councelor Shirley proor B do and
Barton
Ward and I'm Harry Khan governance
officer Harry say to keep me inorder
order and make sure I don't do anything
I shouldn't so are there any
Declarations of interest on any items on
the agenda okay so we have received some
questions from the public um the first
question is around um school holidays uh
the question being
um would' like to know why schools are
able to set their own holidays family
time should be a priority and where
there is no co-ed option for high
schools in the area holidays must be
standardized um for example um the
person that's sent in the question has a
son and a daughter who don't have any
holidays together in February or at the
Easter break
um person has never taken the children
out of school and probably doesn't want
to however I think the question
regarding fines needs asking on behalf
of parents wanting cheaper holidays
especially in a cost of living PR
crisis um I don't know if we're going to
provide a written answer or a verbal one
Karen thank you um I can give you a
verbal update and then follow it up with
a written response if if that will be
helpful um in terms of school holidays
the local Authority is responsible for
setting dates for community and
voluntary control schools um and in
terms
ofies um and free schools which I think
are probably the schools that the um
member of public is referring to in the
bough uh that Duty lies with their
governing board um and or with the trust
uh depending on the delegation of
responsibilities we have been made aware
of the issue by another uh family member
which we have responded to uh and we've
actually shared the feedback from
families to the heads of the schools as
well um quite recently we had the
secondary head teachers meeting last
week where we we were discussing the
next round of school holidays uh what we
we um always Endeavor to consult with
all of the schools uh we also have to
take into account our neighboring
Authority school dates as well
Manchester Salford cheser East for
example um and again I think the schools
recognize that they will work better
together in the future to make sure
there's greater alignment But ultimately
the responsibility does sit with their
governing bodies and trusts okay thank
you Karen I know how frustrating it is
as a former parent myself and now as a
grandparent to try and tee up um
holidays and child care and what have
you so we have um another question
around the Healthy Start agenda item um
what are children and young people's
views on inequality and how have their
views and opinions been
collected and there's been just one
mention in the reports of the be well s
survey um will Trafford be doing any
more EV valuation of the data from that
survey as it gives a detailed
understanding of how our children and
young people are don't know who's going
to come in on that one is it K yeah yeah
and obviously we'll cover a bit more on
the agenda item but just in response to
those questions and I'll follow up with
the written response after this um so on
the first question uh what are children
and young people's views on inequality
and how have their views and opinions
been collected um uh we want to thank
the the uh sender for that question
um which is very pertinent there um are
some programs of work and um described
in the paper which have involved
engagement sometimes that's referred to
sometimes it may not have been
specifically in that paper um but um we
do recognize that there's not uh been
usually the focus on um inequalities
more generally it's often been on a
specific piece of service development
Etc um and so uh more we think can be
done now to bring together those uh data
and insights from Individual pieces of
work with a more kind systematic and
deeper analysis of young people's
experiences of inequalities um and that
will form part of the next stage of
embedding Children's Advocacy and
participation in all our work um there's
an existing participation and engagement
strategy 2022 to2 um which outlines the
um ways that Trafford is committed to
harnessing um and uh young people's
voices and using this um and those
groups uh who were involved in the
strategy including uh children and Care
Council youth watch Trafford youth
cabinet um uh and at the Aftercare forum
and others um some of those bring
together young people with particular
experiences who are often less wellard
for example and some of that is referred
those groups are referred to in the
paper um there's a lot of work going on
with those groups and with Partners in
amongst around the council to review the
uh participation and engagement strategy
and the current uh infrastructure um and
make sure that it's um that the voices
of young people are um engaged and reach
the right strategic fors and decision
makers
um there's some new uh or change
Staffing Arrangements in place and the
plans are being updated to reflect the
current uh context um as per the
recommendations in the paper the new
Farah health for Trafford group and uh
start well board will support these
plans and embed a link to this uh
engagement and participation
infrastructure as a core part of their
work going forward um on the um question
second question which uh refers to the
bwell survey um uh this year's survey is
just closing uh this week we believe and
we believe approximately 16 secondary
schools signed up uh to that one so B
well survey does provide a useful
breakdown by neighborhood which is often
hard to Source from other data sets as
we found when putting together this this
paper uh but the results do require some
further interrogation and
interpretation um and it must be born in
mind that the survey is completed by
specific schools um and specific you
know people within specific schools so
it's not a representative sample but it
is nonetheless a useful starting point
for some some of our questions um there
is a dashboard developed by the
University of Manchester to provide an
after glance uh view um for
neighborhoods and different authorities
to compare with each other and anybody
with an interest can access some of that
so we'd be happy to take views on how to
make that most accessible and use that
information um wider so in terms of
within the council previously the
results have been shared through the
startwell board to consider the
implications for partners um and school
it's valuable that schools also have a
line of sight to those findings for eles
um the findings have informed
commissioning plans and our referenc in
the mental health joint strategic needs
assessment and once this year's findings
have been published um we're committed
to taking the findings through those
young people's engagement mechanisms
that we referred to uh previously to
supplement uh the high level data if you
like with local Insight and
interpretation um and it's suggested
that uh then a kind of Workshop style
session uh will be considered for
professionals to further interpret that
and form recommendations for what uh to
respond to what our young people are
saying super thank you very much for
that very detailed um explanation
um okay um the next item is the minutes
from the previous meeting
um is everybody happy with the content
of the minutes any
changes or mistakes at all okay um
committee happy to accept the minutes
then thank
you okay so we're going on to our next
report which is um item five and this is
School attendance I think this is Karen
that's going to um present this to us um
it's something that I think concerns us
all um particularly post pandemic so we
could give us we have had the papers
Karen so but I know it's quite a meaty
piece of work thank you thank thank you
very much um I think to start with it's
just recognizing in May 22 DFE published
a guidance that was labeled working
together to improve School attendance um
this guidance is currently non-statutory
um but the secretary of state has
committed to making it statutory um as
as Parliament time allows this guidance
has been produced to help Define the
roles and
responsibilities
sorry of uh local authorities of schools
of multi-academy trusts governing bodies
to maintain those high levels of
attendance uh so it's very clear who's
responsible for what within the
guidance what I would say is the
Trafford attendance team have actually
had quite considerable external scrutiny
over the last couple of weeks um around
attendance that has included meeting
with the DFE and also meeting with our
regional senior HMI
um uh in in ofstead to discuss our
position around children and young
people's attendance and our strategies
uh with regard to the DFE um improving
School attendance document both were
received really positively um and and
were met with Support over the
activities that are taking place um by
the team and across our burough what I
would say is they were particularly um
proud as are we of our attendance day
dat for Trafford overall were one of the
highest in the country in terms of our
attendance data um which doesn't happen
by accident you know clearly our schools
and services are working really hard to
continue to ensure children um attend
school I have provided the various data
you've got there the latest published
data from 2122 there's always a lag in
terms of what's published uh for in in
ter in in the public domain and
hopefully that reflects the strong
attendance picture for for children
particularly with send you then have the
attendance data for
2223 uh and you can see there that some
of the the area of need where perhaps we
have to do more is in the secondary
sector uh you'll see that overall and
through the various vulnerable groups
and then what we've tried to do is give
you one of the most current data
pictures so that's for Autumn term one
of 2023 and again we've tried to break
it down into the various vulnerable
groups the next bit I think the analogy
of the impact of loss learning um due to
absence for schools is is really
considerable when you think of it in its
entirety of 80% if a child is attending
80% every year over five years that
equates to one whole year of Education
loss and I think that really does um
give a really clear picture of the
impact of lost
learning as I said we are working hard
to really improve uh School attendance
and we've been clear that it's
everybody's business it isn't just the
work of the attendance team that it it
it it goes far and wide because it
really does require schools and partners
to work collaboratively with and not
against families and we're really clear
about that and some of the more legal
measures that are presented at the end
of the document were really clear when
we support and advise schools that this
is the absolute last result and that is
something we we're really clear about
officers have established model draft
attendance policy that was at the ask of
schools uh and that is again aimed at
getting consistency and Equity across
the bough for all of our
schools um there is also guidance that's
been produced to really enhance the
culture around uh attendance in school
and also some of the um reporting
monitoring and tracking of data that
schools are required to do it's
something that Asad will check when they
inspect
schools the team has uh produced a
graduated approach and that quite
clearly hopefully explains the graduated
approach uh to monitoring and supporting
around attendance and we've devised
priorities that we are working on um in
in terms of work streams um our approach
is around tracking the attendance data
it's working with our schools and it's
also working with our families and young
people I have described the emotionally
based school on attendance because I
think that is something that we are
acutely aware of particularly post
pandemic and is something that is is
incredibly worrying
uh for all of us um this is not about
young people and children refusing to go
to school this is about children and
young people who aren't able to attend
school um the actual um guidance uh
toolkit that has been produced has been
done so by our EP our EP service has led
um in in working with colleagues from
across GM actually to develop this
toolkit um and that really explains the
factors um on attendance difficulties
difficulties that that children might
have in terms of relationships with
peers with adults their negative
experiences of transition experiences of
learning and also their emotional
well-being and mental health and that
real reduced sense of school belonging
so the toolkit is there to offer advice
and guidance and strategies for schools
to employ with children but what we're
really clear about is trying to do that
at the very start once a child stops
attending even just for one day that's
the time to really get in and work with
Children and Families before it becomes
more difficult to move I've also tried
to explain the wider Family Help
approach that we have in Trafford uh
through the family help offer including
Trafford teen together and the work of
our targeted Family Support where we are
seeing attendance as being one of those
factors that is is shared by our
families and the work of the Virtual
School uh Lindsay as head of the virtual
school is acutely aware that uh
attendance for cared for children is a
real concern for us uh and is not where
we want it it to be so the governing
body and the Strategic Improvement plan
that Lindsay holds as the virtual school
has got a very clear priority around
improving attendance and have identified
the strategies that the virtual school
employs for those vulnerable
cohorts one of the expectations is that
from the guidance that has been produced
by DFE which will ultimately become
statutary is to hold targeting support
meetings for every school and that's on
a termly basis now we've not had any
increased capacity that has been brought
into the team because uh DFE have said
the funding is already there so we have
to find a way of actually managing that
with such a small team so we've begun by
rag rating our schools so that we can
offer a prioritized approach um and
working with those red schools to get in
there first uh and have the conversation
around any concerns that they have
around attendance and the kind of
strategies that are in place and the
final bit of the report just explains
the legal interventions as I said which
were really clear as a last result thank
you thanks Karen does anybody have any
questions at all okay um councelor
suon um yeah thank
you thank you um yes a huge piece of
work this report and um absolutely the
um the ebsn uh issues post pandemic are
a huge concern um a couple of things I
wanted to um ask about first uh I read
this report alongside the September
update of keeping children safe and
education um which of course is statute
guidance um and this year's update uh to
that document uh specifically lists uh
persistent absence as one of the
potential early signs of safeguarding
issues um this didn't s this then when I
looked at the the the way the the five
level graduated approach is
presented um I felt that there needs to
be a more specific uh inclusion of uh
this specific statutary need to consider
um levels two three and four is all
possibly indicating uh saf guarding
concerns it lists child may be
vulnerable but um that it doesn't feel
to me specific enough especially it's
going out in in a model document for
schools to use uh that the way
safeguarding issue comes across as being
only the most severe cases of all um is
it something we could just look at um
it's it really hopefully is no more than
adding in a line to levels two three and
four to just make sure that it's all all
those levels it's quite clear that this
needs to be kept in
mind thank you thank you for that I'll
bring Martina in in a moment around the
the graduated approach I think one of
the the things I would say um certain
yes we recognize that attendance is a is
a a protective Factor attendance at
school is is a protective factor for
some of our um vulnerable young people
uh and certainly that the work of the
virtual school because of the expended
duties Lindsay is has got greater
oversight of children who who
potentially are child in need child
protection or have ever had a social
worker so there's a lot more strategic
oversight of again around thinking about
the safeguarding risks uh of what that
looks like uh currently there are panel
meetings happening every week that
Lindsay steps up to look at some of the
most vulnerable children um you as well
Martin have had the Ki meetings which
again is children who are at risk of
missing education and that's a multi-
agency approach actually where we bring
in social workers um youth workers a
whole range of um of services to
consider the circumstances that sit
behind the absence of what needs to be
done um particularly thinking about the
safeguarding risks but do you want to
come in on that Martin at
all
um hear me right um yeah
um in terms of um safeguarding we
[Music]
doy
work particular issue um it's it's
imperative um as well that we do address
consisted absence as soon as we possibly
can and that's a big piece of work
obviously because of the rates of
persistent absence are so high um and we
are really working on um on that with
schools um and they're very keen to look
at you know various different um
strategies to enable that to be reduced
and the way that we see it to local
Authority is to work together um to be
able um to improve persistent because
absolutely is a a massive safe
concern can I just invite Zoe to come in
because one of the things that I think
we do do as a service as a directorate
is that we think about safeguarding in
its broader sense and I think that links
to your question about how we're
applying the graduated response and
obviously that links very much to our
family help and our traffic team
together model zoor yeah thanks very
much for that comment and I couldn't
agree with you more really that
obviously PA is a a real concern and
keeping our children safe is absolutely
crucial I think what I am very
passionate about um in terms of the
family help agenda is early intervention
and prevention and actually I think and
I hope it comes through in our strategy
and if it doesn't we need to make sure
it does is that we don't wait for it to
get to
50% um because actually what what one of
the services that I manage is Trafford
team together which is actually a huge
investment and commitment to a family
help offer which is um a kind of a team
around the school approach where we're
inviting schools to talk to us about the
the children young people they've got
concerns about but at the earliest
opportunities so I can tell you already
we' not got full roll out of Trafford
team together we've committed to that in
Spring 24 um but I can tell you already
I'm looking at the data out of
299 families that were supported through
Trafford team together last year I can
tell you that 36% of those families our
children young people that were flagged
due to attendance issues at the earliest
opportunity so actually looking at when
it's even getting to below 90% not
waiting for it to get to
50% what I do think's really important
picking up on your point is that
actually as part of our strategy and
approach we know that neglect and other
issues is a bit of a key concern for us
so in actual fact where we are getting
concerns around a child or family then
actually as part of our neglect work we
would want somebody to be visiting that
child or young person's home and that's
certainly something we'll be looking at
and and ensuring is promoted in terms of
our te our traffic team together
approach so I hope that gives you some
assurance that that actually you know
here in Trafford we don't want to wait
for it to get to PA we we've actually
got strategies in place that get in
there before that point we recognize
that there are other circumstances where
unfortunately it does get to that point
but but we're we're there really with
that team around the child and and and
[Music]
family just to add to that as well there
is a clear expectation that if children
are absent from school uh schools have
to make contact with children and
families and the expectation is that
they will need to see eyes on so they're
acutely aware of the safeguarding risk
that sit around on attendance as
well thank you councelor Enis thank you
chair and thank you for the
comprehensive report um I hear what
Karen's saying about the fact that
traffic's fairing better than the rest
of the country but with absences the way
they are nationally that's a little bit
like saying our house is slightly less
on fire than the rest of the street
isn't it teachers I think in particular
are really worried and uh with school
absences at in Trafford I think trending
not down and I think the most alarming
statistic you've provided here is the
persistent absence rate for 22 23 up 2%
on last year while the national average
is stayed stagnant so that tells a
slightly different story quite an
alarming one but the early intervention
that zo highlighted I think before it
gets to persistent absence I think
that's really welcome and it shows that
we are looking at that very seriously
I'll try and run through my questions as
quickly as I can chair um are there any
specific days of the week that crop up
as more Miss than others how does school
absence data from those year groups that
started primary before the pandemic
compare with year groups that were at
school during the covid years and
looking at the 23 uh 24 term one rates
of persistent absence uh for children
with an EHC plan that's nearly four in
10 children with an EHC missing an
alarming amount of school time right at
the age when we're starting to think
about their transition to adulthood what
do you think needs to change in order to
bring that those specific rates down and
how many children in Trafford at the
moment with an EHC plan are currently
without a school
place okay now I might have to ask you
to repeat some of those questions
because that was a lot of information to
take on firstly can I just provide
Assurance just because we are very high
that doesn't mean that we're complacent
you know I don't want that to come
across as you know uh that that we feel
everything's okay because we know it's
not um what we are doing is is clearly
trying to recognize what's working well
in order to get sustained effective
practice across the bough so I do I do
want to you know just provide Assurance
around that um I'm going to bring
um um Sarah in shortly just around um
some of the data changes um what I will
say about I think you referred to some
of the data for children with EHC plans
um being particularly low um we have
done some analysis around this and this
kind of play into our targeting of
schools so we're really clear from a
individual School level where those
attendance where that attendance data
impacts on the overall data we know that
in for example one of our special
schools has some of the most complex
young people that attends uh the school
and their attendance data has really
been impacted certainly since covid um
they are suggesting that there are
absolutely um quite entrenched behaviors
now uh which are becoming really
difficult to manage um those young
people may have had lower attendance in
their previous school um and those
patterns then are repeated once they get
into or they're placed into this
particular special school what they've
tried to do to kind of counteract some
of those issues is to create an offsite
placement that is run by the school
staff but it's there to try and manage
some of the the barriers that these
young people have in terms of returning
back into
education um and and it's done in a in a
way that's getting them ready to get
back to those previous attendance uh
records and be reintegrated back into
the special school that they attend so
schools are trying to be really um I
suppose quite quite clever um and and uh
really trying to be creative in in
trying to address what the barriers are
in order order to return children back
to education as best they can some young
people are on part-time timetables in a
bid to try and bring them back up to the
levels that they need to be at um which
has been recommended by government as
well um as a strategy that needs to be
employed um some of these young people
have quite severe medical difficulties
as well which is obviously hindering
some of their um you know ability to to
access school and therefore maybe
accessing tutoring again with a bid to
just making sure there's a level of
Education in place for these young
people um do you want to come in on the
date a bit Sarah because I know you did
some analysis around this shifts in data
that might be helpful for
you
yeah um so if you pull the whole thing
near to you you won't have to bend over
right that thanks
thanks um okay in the in the report and
the the trends that you talked about
with regards to PA rates I think it's
important to note that the attendance
data for
2223 is indicative and that it's not yet
been through a verification process yet
but actually in the last week we've had
some new published data which is the
most up to-date and verified data for
Trafford and we do know that our PA rate
when compared to the same time the year
before has gone down by 2.8 percentage
points um and it's
14.5% overall compared to 21% nationally
so it is significantly better than the
national rate and the most sort of the
most significant Improvement that we've
seen is in the secondary sector PA rate
and we've got an improvement of 4.1
percentage points for that period so
we're down to 16.1% PA in secondary
compared to
25.2%
nationally and then
just thinking about the send pupils
which you also talked about um the PA
rate there is higher and I think it's a
for ehcp children 27.9% in Trafford but
that is an improvement of two percentage
points on the previous year um and
that's actually going against the
national uh sorry that that's better
than the national rate again 8.4
percentage points better than the
national rate and there's a similar
picture with send support children where
we've seen an Improvement of 4.9
percentage points so we've got 21%
persistently absent and that's going
against the national Trend where they've
seen a worsening position and it's
almost 10 percentage points better than
National so I think we do still have
work to do particularly with our
vulnerable cohorts and these you're
right the national picture is is not a
healthy picture but I think in terms of
the direction of travel and in terms of
us reducing some of those High numbers
we're on the right
trajectory
I'm not sure whether we're able to
provide you with the year group I think
you asked for year group attendance data
was that interesting to see if you can
get that granularity even if it comes
after after the meeting and that
probably applies to um my other
question which yeah which was days of
the week yeah which probably isn't
available now but yeah that would be an
analysis with schools I think you know
those but again we can probably pull
something off I think Martina and get
that to you if that's possible yeah I
could just perhaps confirm about the
year groups and the absence by year
group and it increases year on year the
levels of absence from reception up to
year 11 which and it's cons just
consistently on a trajectory like that
that's the national picture and also the
picture in Trafford um I'm not days of
the week is that um yeah I was just
going to come in for days of the week
now historically um it's been Mondays
and Fridays and what we are able to do
though going forward is to make is is to
really sort of dig deep deep and analyze
the data which is one thing that we've
not been able to do um before um because
we've we're quite data rich now for the
first time which is absolutely brilliant
so um Our intention is to be able to um
analyze the data obviously as much as we
can look at cohorts um and look at um
days like you say days of the week
because it's really important that we do
capture that information um but what
we're finding at the moment as well just
on that point of absence um and days of
the week is um a big a significant
increase um in leave of absence and term
time so holidays um parents are take we
you know we we've already seen an
increase from this time last year um in
terms of um referrals for penalty
notices from schools so that's really
really on the increase at the
moment did that cover all you're happy
okay got counsel Paul did you want to
come
in
hello yeah everybody can hear me right
yeah uh thank you for the report it's
quite in depth and uh yeah so uh there
was one point that I was a bit concerned
about so could the members please advise
what procedures are in place if a pupil
is not attending school due to bullying
and school has not done enough to
address the issue so basically is that
something that parents can refer to
services are directly to counselors and
in such circumstances what remedy to
counselors or councel have in order to
sort The Bullying
issue okay again we probably don't hold
that level of detail um it kind of
probably plays into some of the uh work
that we've done around emotionally based
School non attendance because if
children are citing that there are
issues with friendships and struggles
with peers um that is something that is
mentioned in our epner toolkit that we
provide for schools it probably also
comes up through the Trafford teen
together meetings as well and and again
um we're able to work with families
through those meetings to certainly try
to see what the school is doing to
resolve the problem but equally provide
some additional support for the young
person if needed do you want to come in
Zoe um yeah thank you very much for that
question um sorry bit hard when you're
that way isn't it um yeah I just wanted
to say that actually um that is
something that we we do pick up in terms
of the Trafford team together approach
and I think it's come up in terms of a
trend a little bit more in the south of
the bah um so that is something that
we're aware of in terms of those kind of
needs and we kind of then that informs
some of the work that we're doing we um
in terms of the Trafford team together
approach one of the things that that's
really strong about it is that we
capture um child and young person voice
really clearly so that um our approach
has just been evaluated by uh Stockport
families and um that's that's what we
make sure that we really do well so that
actually it really starts with what the
child or young person is saying is the
problem in their own words really so
what we try and do is work very much
with the child the young person and also
the school in terms of if there's any
any adjustments or any things that need
looking at particularly there and really
come at that from a whole family
approach um I'd like to think that
schools are quite
um uh attuned to some of that and um and
and in terms of that approach really
work together with um a range of
services where that's an issue so I
don't know whether that answers but it
we we do really make sure that the the
child's voice and experience is is at
the heart of what we
do so if we do get any kind of emails
from parents saying that they are having
such kind of issue so we would then
refer it to a home
basically maybe if I can come in there
um in in terms of of the uh pupil
absence uh Team so um parents do contact
us um
directly um and we will then um speak to
the parents speak to the school um and
try and liaz um and obviously just get
to the to the bottom of the problem um
so parents are quite often advised to
come through to us so that we can have
those um discussions with the school so
that we can get the the whole picture um
and then um advise accordingly I mean it
might might be a meeting in school to
address those issues um you know
hopefully that's that's what we're about
we're about resolution as quickly as
possible um so that the young person is
out of school for obviously the limited
amount of amount of
time as counselors would it be possible
for us to have the contact details for
that team I think that would be helpful
wouldn't it okay yeah um just something
sorry I just uh latched on to there
saying Zoe about the increase in the
south of the B could that be due due to
the inequalities across the B I.E more
children have access to social media
perhaps in the South and do in the north
I me this is the worry to me bullying
has always gone on in schools we know
that but I just think for for the young
people today it's 247 you don't get home
and it stops and you know it's it's
ongoing throughout the evening there's
no peace no rest from from it is I think
that's a really um important point and I
think um I think what we often say I
don't want to say that it's necessarily
bullying but we see a higher incidence
of friendship kind of issues in terms of
of that I think what I remember has been
really helpful and it was a very
pertinent question is actually around
the be well survey because that really
does pick up the child and Young
Person's voice and it'll be very
interesting to see how that B well
survey compares to previous B well
surveys and whether that um that
information is triangulated through that
that that child voice and young person
voice
really thank you councelor
Parker thank you thanks so much for this
report and it's really good to see like
how much data is in there because you
know I'm a data geek so thank you so
much it was really helpful um on that I
it's suggested in the report that locked
after children are those who are most at
risk and that they're three times more
likely to be persistently absent the
other thing on that note was that
there's only four attendance offices in
place for those pupils so my question is
that as the council comes under more
financial pressure how can we guarantee
then that the needs and well-being of
looked after children are not going to
be
deprioritized and I flag that because
even when it comes to addressing the
emotionally based
non-attendance focus is very much given
to parental engagement um and support
but nothing speaks to the locked after
children and even in the case studies
that are referred to the children who
have parents are the ones who initiate
the action so what of the voiceless
children um they are my concern and
secondly I'm conscious that the
responses have have been very much
around uh the Trafford team together
model now am I correct in thinking
that's not been rolled out yet in sales
central so my concern is what's filling
the Gap in that
location thank you I'll do the first bit
around the car for children the virtual
school um I think the four officers are
probably in the attendance team not
necessarily the virtual school team
unless I've possibly misrepresented that
in the report um so apologies if that's
the case um you you're absolutely right
that obviously the attendance of our
cared for children is is a concern um
there's a lot of analysis has gone into
understanding the reasons for that um
some of which is actually term time
holidays uh which is which is
interesting and that has been raised um
with with our partners in children's
social care um and there's been a a
concerted effort into um ensuring that
there's there's greater oversight who
signs off and authorizes those holidays
as well uh and those place with parents
as well um so that there is a bit more
that kind of sits under the the analysis
of the the cared for children the
virtual school has I think has got a
really rich resource in terms of
managing um the needs of of the the
either looked after children or the
cared for children who come under the
virtual school and they've employed
learning mentors um uh uh counselors
therapists all sorts of support
particularly if there are children who
are really struggling um in terms of
their emotional health and well-being so
whilst we recognize it is a concern uh
Lindsay it as I said it's there on this
their Virtual School development plan
it's an improvement um and the weekly
panels are also providing that real
in-depth understanding and discussion
multi- agency discussion around the
individual cases and how you know what
strategies what further interventions
and support support can be put into
place for those young people Jill do you
want to come in on that I do yes because
just in terms of the virtual school I
would absolutely agree with Karen that
it is a well resourced um Virtual School
one of the the most resourced that I've
seen in my experience and at the the
last corporate parenting board two weeks
ago we did have a deep dive that
included what we are doing for the
education of our our children who are in
our care as Karen's already identified
there is a at work stream that is
inclusive of what we need to do to
increase attendance there are joint
strategies with colleagues in children's
social care and one of the things that
the virtual school has implemented is
the annual Bridge conference that's
about making a bridge between the work
that the virtual school does the work
that goes on in our schools and our our
children's social care services
recognizing that education is a pathway
for a lot of our young people in terms
of over coming some of their
difficulties a pathway to achievement so
it's really something that there is a
collaborative Endeavor around um and I
think that if if it would be helpful
there is the opportunity to share the
annual report of the virtual school in
the virtual governing body I have to say
you need to set aside a bit of time to
do it because Lindsay like yourself is
very keen on her data and it is um an
in-depth read but that would I hope
provide some Assurance in terms of the
range of services that are available
through the virtual
school um just to check does that data
include how many of those who are part
of the V virtual school go on to higher
education from there too brilliant and
we do really well in terms of that and
we do well in terms of um our cared for
children that go onto
University um so there are some real
successes and you can see the benefits
of us having that well resolved approach
and I think one of the things that's
really quite impressive is is that that
the schools are Keen that we manage the
pupil premium and that we look at that
on individual basis rather than thinking
about how we collaborate because we tie
it to the individual personal education
plans what that means for young people
as well as some of the Staffing resource
like counselors like
psychologists councelor
Bennett thank you I don't think we
should underestimate the effect this has
on parents as well I spoke to a mom who
said it's absolutely agonizing a
daughter sobs every day when she has to
take her to school and she's left with
that feeling of just B bereavement all
through the day and she does take it to
school but she said it's definitely
impacting on their relationship
too
I I you know it's it is heartbreaking to
hear some of hear some of the stories um
and and I really you know feel your you
know the emotion and the compassion
there um as Martinez said you know we we
are going to be through our targeted
work with schools through the
emotionally based School non attendance
because we're actually doing webinars
for f for parents around emotionally
based School non attendance so the
educational psychology service are
hosting those to provide again advice
guidance and support for for parents
because you're absolutely right it
absolutely does impact on on a parents
well-being too so just to provide some
Assurance around that but when we do
have the conversations with the schools
and even when we're doing our quality
assurance visits in the Autumn term the
associate School Improvement advisers
are having a a big focus on attendance
this time they all actually received uh
training from an offed inspector around
attendance so they're going in AR you
you know sort of armed with a with a
real dedicated conversation around how
they're really supporting children and
families and and absolutely you know how
the wider support for the family is
being looked at not just um you know the
child attending
school yeah um perhaps if I can just
come in there as well and just say that
um absolutely support now um for parents
and families is key we're moving away
from the punitive um measures very much
so in line with the DFE strategy um and
um le as Karen mentioned before um any
sort of Parental responsibility measures
are very much a last result so it's all
about you know building those
relationships um with parents is really
key and that communication making sure
that there's communication um between
the school and the parents and working
on who is the best person within the
school to be able to reach out um and
give that parent um the support that
they need so you know rather than go
down the challenging or the or the the
punitive um Channel sort of immediately
it's really about building that support
and giving it a chance to
work thank you councelor
pro thank you chair I too love stats
they make my heart sing because they can
tell us so much I'd like more um more in
depth detail I'd like to
know
what are the causes of
absence and
also does it vary geographically not the
cause the levels of absence because I'd
expected
to
[Music]
and when when I look at them all it's
our most vulnerable children who aren't
attending school
regularly and having not wanting to jump
ahead onto the agenda H having read
other other
reports it looks like we're doing what
we
can I'm sure there's more we can do um
when I looked at our cared for
children surely that's a conversation
with Foster carers on the don't take
them out of school you get a holiday
allowance use it because these children
need to be in
school so so yeah what I'd like is is
more data
on geography and on causes of absence
please
thanks thank you Council Pro I mean that
certainly that's something we can we can
take away if that's helpful we we do
know that attendance is probably um the
the north is is the area of the bough
where we see the highest rates of of
absence um I think there's something we
can probably do to to bring a report
around those um as I say those
geographical imbalances if you like um
it can probably come from some of the
investigations that come from the
Trafford team together but also the um
Asia reports that will be coming in in
the Autumn term from the schools because
we'll get a really clear understanding
from the individual schools about the
causes and what are the barriers but
equally what the strategies that they're
employing so we can bring a report
another time thank you just to come back
in on your question about Foster careers
and agreements for children to have
unauthorized absence and go on holiday
that was one of the things that Karen
referred to earlier in terms of taking
that forward from some of the analysis
from some of the reporting by the
virtual school what I can say is that
we've genuinely strengthened our
engagement and our um forums for foster
carers and we have a full modernization
plan around fostering so the
conversation looks very different than
it might have done a couple of years ago
in terms of being able to both support
and challenge our foster care as in an
in an appropriate way and that was
certainly something that was picked up
in the corporate parenting board two
weeks ago just to say as well we do have
foster care Representatives on the
virtual school governing body as well so
you know we we're using every Avenue we
can to to gain that
support
so sorry is it is it okay I feel like I
didn't finish um you had one other the
question and I just want to provide some
reassurance and go back if that's okay
um you mentioned about TTT not being um
there's a lot of T's there and sometimes
I say too many um not always being uh
not not yet in Central and you're
absolutely right about that what I
wanted to just give some Assurance about
is we do have What's called the early
help panel that is a kind of um so
that's a multi- agency panel it was
actually um part of our peer review from
stop Port so we we reviewed the TTT
model but also our early help panel and
um one of the things that I know I'm not
allowed to talk about it too much Jill
but what came out of the send um
inspection was the strength of our early
Health panels because actually we've got
GPS and other health professionals that
sit around that panel that multi- agency
panel so actually where schools have got
concerns they can bring it to that panel
for discussion and support so I didn't
want anybody to go away today thinking
that if traa team together wasn't in a
particular area that families were left
with nothing because they they're not I
just wanted to provide that Assurance
but we are still committed to the
traffic team together approach so thank
you for letting me come back in there
thanks so so I've got councelor Deacon
and then a final question I think from
counselor oh and then councelor I'll
take counselor Deacon councilor Duncan
and then councelor Sun if that's
all sorry um my question was actually
around the uh psychology service um and
just noting the fact that's obviously
done on with consent of the young people
and their parents what the take up of
that is like and uh the extent to which
that has the resource and the capacity
it need to to manage the obviously the
massive challenge they've seen yeah in
terms of the emotionally based School
non attendance that you're talking about
yeah absolutely um have we I don't know
whether we've got any f data on on the
takeup we've it's it's certainly been
rolled out um amongst most of our
schools I'll come back to you with the
exact data I know it's something that we
shared at the send inspection have you
got it Sarah 85% thank you very much so
it's uh it's certainly well received by
our schools um there is a uh emotionally
based school on attendance the EP um
Steering group as well um of which we
have parents on that group um as well as
other providers
uh partners and schools and that's all
about just making sure that we
understand the impact what the pathways
are going to be as a result of rolling
out the toolkit um and what where the
gaps are and what the wider offer needs
to be um so but I can it's certainly
something again we can bring some
further detail to you if that be
helpful yeah sorry just to add to that
um I suppose it's it's worth just
explaining that it is a toolkit that's
rolled out to school so what's great
about it is the educational psychology
service don't need to deliver it
directly themselves um because otherwise
there wouldn't struggle in terms of
capacity so we've got really high take
up of that the thing that I just wanted
to share from an early intervention
point of view is there is an early um
identification tool kit um or screening
that runs alongside that so as part of
our traffic team together approach what
we're actually going to be saying is
when children are in year five um we are
going to be asking schools to have a bit
of a focus on that because what we do
know is it's when they move up
particularly sometimes into a a bigger
secondary school that that becomes a bit
more of a concern but if we can see the
red flags a bit earlier it means we're
we're able to do something about it a
bit earlier as
well
so yeah thank you very much everybody um
yeah really informative report thank you
um I along with councelor Paul um
represent Mana Ward and for those that
are unsure that also has the sale West
estate okay along Manor Avenue um now
unless I've missed anything would it be
possible please to break down your
absence
data per school and per Ward across
Trafford if that's not already provided
please thank
you mean we certainly do have school
level data for the vast majority of our
schools because schools are actually
submitting that through through a portal
the DFE um not made it mandatory but
they' always requested it um certainly
as a result of covid really uh so it's
something we can do and then break it
down into WS as well if that' be
helpful thank you very much thank you
yeah that that would be really
interesting I think for for anybody here
um certainly World byward School by
school would be really useful um ask a
final question for counselor something
okay thanks hopefully this is quite a
quick one uh going back to the uh model
uh attendance policy um the section on
rewards and incentives which is a very
relevant section to be including and
it's quite appropriate that it's left
for schools to make uh decisions
themselves because they know what what
will work for them them uh but one thing
that has uh always got my back up is uh
rewards for 100% attendance uh because
it's such a crude and obvious piece of
discrimination and stigma against uh
children with for example chronic health
conditions for whom 100% attendance
simply is never uh going to happen um
and also kids aren't dumb when they see
one of their peers or friends being
discriminated that against in that way
then it discredits the entire incentive
system in the first Place uh so would it
be possible to include in that uh model
document a recommendation to avoid 100%
rewards I don't know whether Martina
wants to to come in on this
one uh yes um that I totally agree with
you and it is something that we can add
in I hopefully to reassure you um we do
have conversations with schools about
that exact issue um because we we really
take take that on board yes um and and
in the main School
are fine with that so yes I think that
would be a good
addition I think it's always worth
remembering as well you know it's it's
also good for us to look at authorized
absence and unauthorized because that
you know obviously that's where illness
will will
Factor okay thank you so much um
such surrounded by such knowledge and I
it always amazes me how quickly it can
just provide the data and the answers
that we ask for um and thank you to
members for the questions um I don't
know who's staying and who's leaving for
the next I'm sure if you want to leave
us you you're very welcome but thank you
for attending thank
you so we going to move on to item six
which is the complex safeguarding annual
report um don't know who's going
somebody going to so chair if it would
be helpful I I'll introduce the report
cour and then um Tracy stains who's the
head of vulnerable adolescence um
service will draw out the key points and
and highlights um we we felt very much
that this would be a report that was of
interest and um hopefully of use to to
scrutiny committee what you will have
seen is that this is the first time
we've produced an annual report in terms
of the work of our complex safeguarding
team
I think it's really important to to
recognize that safeguarding work is
something that's done in Partnership but
in the area of complex safeguarding it's
it's probably even more important that
it's seen as a partnership Endeavor
having said that this is the activity
that is very much by the local Authority
team we've recognized that this is an
area of local and National interest and
focus and as we've already touched upon
for some of our young people it's an
area of growing
concern the impact of social media the
impact of adults that want to behave in
a harmful way towards young people is
something that is is fast-paced and and
changing um we're very much open to
questions and we hope that it will be of
interest to you recognizing that um it
is the first time that we have done this
report I am sure there will be
suggestions observ
Reflections in terms of the sorts of
things that you would want to see moving
forward what I do hope is that the
report gives you um an indication of how
seriously we take the issues that we
have a very clear strategic approach and
that strategic approach ranges from
prevention to prosecution of those
people that behave in a behave in a
harmful way towards our young people I
hope you also get a strong flavor that
very much it is about being child young
person centered and about seeing all
young people as victims and at that
point I'm probably going to pause and
hand over to
Tracy thank you Jill just checking
there's no feedback on this microphone
like this time um I thought it would be
really useful um because I know that
people have read the report so I thought
it'd be really useful to pick out the
highlights in terms of the achievements
and in terms of the reflections from
2022 and
2023 and refer to how that has made a
difference to the young people that
we're working with um so just as a start
in terms of one of the highlights and in
terms of the achievements we do have a
really strong stable uh Staffing um
resource so we have um we're well
resourced we have um stability and good
retention in terms of Staffing um low
rates of interim workers um with just
one um interim practice manager and one
inter social worker at the moment
covering for maternity but in terms of
the impact that that has for young
people what it does is provide them with
continuity in terms of having a worker
that um can they can build a trusting
relationship with so it's it's really
positive and it's it's um you know I
think what young people have said to us
in terms of their feedback is that they
do have trusted relationships with the
professionals that they work with um one
of the other strengths in terms of a
achievements for 2223 is the fact that
we do have an awful lot of expertise in
in the complex safeguarding team so what
we've focused on is um training and
development and we pull on resources
from the greater Manchester combined
Authority from um third sectors who we
invite to our Bim monly uh service
meetings and that enables us to
understand our young people and to meet
the needs of the young people because of
the expertise in in the service so
that's that's really positive we've done
an awful lot of work in terms of
development of the complex safeguarding
service in
2223 um so we have and one of the
highlights I think is around our
partnership working and the
relationships that we have with our
partners so we've we've reviewed and
strengthened a lot of the multi- agency
working processes that we have in place
such as our daily risk management
meetings which are multi-agency um
including police health education youth
Justice um and our complex safeguarding
service um we've also um developed the
shine panel um which is again um really
well resourced with partners and we've
also strengthened our national referral
mechanism process so all in all that's
enabled us to respond to our young
people really quickly on a daily basis
so our daily risk management meetings in
the morning every morning Monday to
Friday and that the police alert us to
any concerns that they have with our
young people so therefore we can respond
on on the same day which is is really
necessary because a lot of our young
people often go missing when when they
become involved with the with the police
um in terms of the shine panel what
that's enabled us to do is to have that
really robust oversight of not just
referrals in to the shine panel for our
young people but also referral reviews
so every three months every young person
is review reviewed and also decisions
about whether a young person should be
closed to shine and that's held and
accountable from from the multi-agency
group so um it also allows us at the
panel to look at what the needs of the
young people are and refer to the right
the right Services if they're not going
to be referred into service or allocated
to shine just thinking Beyond shine one
of the strengths um for the national
referral mechanism is that we now have
uh pre nrm we refer to
prrm meetings um and those multi-
agencies so what that does is support us
to strengthen our submissions um in
terms of um whether somebody is a victim
of exploitation and whether they can be
seen as such so we have it at the moment
I mean this isn't 22 23 data but I know
at the moment we have 17 um reasonable
and conclusive grounds in terms of
submissions so um there's a case uh
study in the report but what that does
is prevent our young people from being
criminalized when in fact they're a
victim of exploitation criminal
exploitation another uh of the
highlights that I wanted to mention was
the wide range of AED activity that we
have um so that's across a strategic
safeguarding partnership peer reviews um
our own file audits um and that enables
us to meet the needs of our young people
to understand what the needs are and
understand what the gaps are in service
so then we can start to look at what we
need to do in terms of plans and going
forward to make those improvements for
our young
people and we do get the regular
performance data which again is is a a
strength because that enables us to
understand specifically what patterns
and themes are at hand in terms of
affecting our young people so that will
enable us when we dig down into the data
and we look at the narrative and the
story behind that we can see patterns
and themes in terms of um perhaps hot
spots in terms of areas um of
exploitation um we can also look at
whether there are um specific themes in
terms of adult perpetrators and
organized criminal groups so that's
really useful in terms of supporting us
to work with our partners to um prevent
and protect and pursue prosecution of
those
perpetrators um what we know from the
data is that we have um a low um
re-referral rate into the complex
safeguarding Service uh we just have to
be a bit cautious because of the small
numbers when we say percentages that
actually links to quite a small number
of young people so just to treat with
caution but actually we've got an 11% um
from 22 23 11% re re-referral rating
which equates to three young people so
that that's a measure in terms of or I'm
taking that as a measure in terms of
success of doing that direct work with
young people um just in terms of
Reflections um again one of the
reflections when I was looking through
the report in preparation I was thinking
you know our Workforce whilst it's very
strong and extremely stable it is it is
Fe a female Workforce and we just
reflected on on that in terms of our
numbers of young boys who are open to
complex safeguarding and around criminal
exploitation um but just as an update we
do we have recruited a male social
worker so that that's really positive um
and in terms of Reflections again what
what I thought would be useful to know
is that in terms of urban street gangs
and organized criminal groups what we
know is that's still quite unknown
territory we do have we work very
closely with the police in terms of
intelligence mapping we are collocated
with the police and they have a full
team and you know the relationships are
really robust and we can challenge one
another but actually what what we're
told by our colleagues and places that
it's an Ever evolving picture in terms
of urban street gangs so we never have
definitive information with regards to
that it's an intelligence picture that's
always involving but we were so closely
that we can respond to that Evolution
quite quickly um I think what we need to
be mindful of and one of the the
reflections that have been thinking
about quite recently and in talking with
colleagues about and partners is that
what what we know is that our young
people who are associated with urban
street gangs have been victims of
exploitation but potentially are
exploiters of other young people as well
and we are mindful about that and we are
looking at um how our neighboring local
authorities work with those young people
in terms of offering that specialist
support um because sometimes it's beyond
what what actually we can offer and
there there is a couple of Charities
that other the young PE sorry other the
local authorities are are working with
that I'm going to be looking into 23 to
24 we also Link in with just in terms of
the urban street gang and organized
criminal gangs we also Link in with our
colleagues at Challenger which is a
dedicated police team at ex Excalibur
task force so so um and that is with
regards to the mapping of our young
people across um the urban street gang
and or organized criminal activity so we
we're constantly reviewing that with the
Specialists from the
police uh just just finally just in
terms of continued Reflections um I
think what we have noticed um 2223 is
that it is quite difficult to get some
feedback from our young people and
parents and carers and and you know and
and it's hard hard when we don't get
that and to we don't know how to shape
the service going forward and I think
that needs to be a real Focus um and
drive the complex safeguarding team to
ask our young people and parents and
other professionals what has worked well
you know what do we need to do to
strengthen we do have some feedback and
and it's qualitative feedback and we're
quite Innovative in terms of asking our
young people to do rap music and I think
at this there's a couple of um
demonstrations attached in the report um
and one of our young people think the
shine social workers should get a pay
rise so um they they were quite vocal
with regards to that so we do get the
the the quality feedback but we we think
last 2022 23 was about 36% of our young
people fed back so there is you know
scope to improve on that and we are
working towards that um I think one of
the other Reflections or the the last
kind of reflection that I wanted to to
talk about today was around thinking
about how we can link in um more closely
with schools and with early help what we
have noticed across um complex
safeguarding is that we are working with
far more young people who are suspected
to be exploited and vulnerable to
exploitation ra exploitation sorry
rather than actual exploitation so we
are working with young people earlier um
but and it's very proactive but I do
think there is scope to think about um
identifying earlier indicators for all
young people and then doing a bit of a
thematic analysis around that and seeing
whether there's a scope to work with
early help in schools excuse me got
really try MTH rather than just social
care okay thanks and thank you for the
report it's the first time we've had
this report and it's excellent
absolutely enlightening as to to what's
going on and very reassuring from I
think from our point of you um and I
love your enthusiasm Tracy just um do
anybody have any questions uh councelor
pennett yeah was there any evidence that
this there is familiar patterns in this
is it children within the same family or
is that not a factor and also did Alex
get the pay rise
recommended um thank you um Alex didn't
get the pay
Rise um there is some evidence that the
there it's in extra link some extra
familiar harm and also intrafamiliar
harm and all the young people that are
open to complex safeguarding are either
supported through child in need child
protection or or a cared for young
people um it there are there are very
few cases the majority of of the
concerns are around extra familial harm
but complex safeguarding work alongside
the lead locality social worker so we we
run that in parallel in terms of both
both types of harm and support parents
parents and carers with regards to that
as
well just just to follow up do you think
it's a bigger problem than we're aware
of do you think there's a lot going on
that is beneath the surface and that
very few cases actually come to to to
the fall I think there's if I can just
come in with a little bit of an overview
and from a greater Manchester and a
national perspective one of the things
about the case loads within the the
shine service is we do have a model
that enables the workers to form those
trusted relationships so we deliberately
try and keep the the numbers of of young
people that a dedicated shine worker is
working with quite low there is another
allocated worker who might be doing the
child protection conferences or the
looked after things whilst they work
together very much as a partnership the
one of the remits for the shine workers
is around some of that disruption
activity with the police building that
Rel relationship and having the
intensity so I think one of Tracy's
words of caution about the re-referral
rate I also think that's reflective of
the intensity of the relationship and
you will have seen that for some of our
young people they benefit from the
service for for over a year um one of
the reasons why we have grown the
service is because we do think there's
unmet need and we don't have people
sitting around twiddling their thumbs so
one of the priorities moving forward has
to be that early identification and
actually do our numbers look right
compared to our statistical neighbors
compared to what we know nationally and
I still think our our numbers look on
the low side and I definitely think
there is a wider partnership piece in
terms of not just that awareness raising
but not thinking that this is a teenager
involved in criminality for example that
actually is it symptomatic of of
something else if I can just come back
councelor Bennett to your question about
all their patterns within families for
some young people yes there is a pattern
of of criminality being entrenched and
does that lead to
exploitation it's difficult to say that
that is a linear response but certainly
there is a lot of um external drivers
that are contributing so actually I can
see that person who's got a big flash
car that got the flash trainers and
actually is that going to be an
opportunity for me people who who
exploit our young people use an awful
lot of hooks to to drive that
exploitation one of the things our young
people has said is that exploiters pray
on vulnerable and they look for your
vulnerability so one of our young people
told us really clearly um my mom they
didn't use the word Mom that's my North
East expression Quin out isn't it my mom
doesn't have any money I do this because
I need to help my mom so it it's really
important that we think about the
external factors that are pulling on our
young
people
Council thank you chair it was just a
quick one on the age profile and uh it
do seem to show you know that there's
significant number of kids between 13 14
that seem to get picked up a quarter of
the
and and as you just alluded to you know
the fact that it's probably a very
vulnerable age that you know they've got
no
experiences uh and they're getting all
these kind of incentives dangled in
front of them which they can't associate
with criminality
necessarily uh or unusual behavior
perhaps you know the must get accustomed
to a certain extent
so uh and then it increases
significantly in within that 15 16 AG
group and then it sort of tapers off
quite a bit so you know sort of reflects
on what you're saying and has there been
any um I I know you
obviously quite strong on it as to
what's happening and how to deal with it
has there been any lessons that you're
learning from this any further
improvements that you to make any kind
of
uh research going on in terms of what
what's going on thank you
so as we've alluded to this is an area
where um National findings research the
evidence base as well as the dynamic
nature of the harm and the concerns is
continually growing we do have the
benefit of having a greater Manchester
complex Safe Garden Club and at times
that has very much been at the Forefront
of some of the Innovation some of the
research trac's talked about some of the
experts that we have brought in to
continue to inform our practice one of
the things um I think Tracy was being
slightly harsh on herself and the team
when she talked about um the gender
inequality within the team so we've
recently engaged on a a GM basis with
Lads like us which is a a third sector
organization that has had young men that
have come through the experience of
exploitation um have started to follow a
different path in their life talking to
our practitioners or managers about what
that actually looked like and what that
actually meant so we're always really
mindful for what are the areas of of
best practice in order to inform what
we're doing we're just about to look at
whether we can commission a young woman
who has come through the who openly
shares her experience in terms of
exploitation it's work that's being
commissioned by the police honor a GM
footprint as well and that works called
out of the shadows and and the clues in
the title isn't it you know one point I
was in the shadows and this is how awful
it looked like for me and this is what
it looks like but it's a really great
Point Council but because actually the
interventions that we need to put in
place do need to have an Evidence base
of of what works but actually because
it's a changing evolving picture some of
that evidence base is still emerging so
we have to be vigilant too what's out
there what can we learn what do our
young people say um and what are the
exper in the field telling
us thanks chair Council brought sir
thanks chair thank you for this I've had
to take my glasses off because I need to
read from the screen so you're a bit
blurred I just want have highlighted um
the most recent ofstead inspection
reported the following the response to
child exploitation is more more robust
relational model of Social Work practice
which is well regard guarded by The
Wider World Workforce has been
successfully implemented thank you
that's to to read that is wonderful this
is a an Ever Changing ever evolving
issue so to be told that um you're doing
an amazing job and I thank you for doing
that thank you could could would you is
it okay just back to counc
um I just wanted to offer some assurance
that the younger the young people are so
the 11 to 13 14 year olds are those that
are suspected of being exploited and
vulnerable too and the 15 to 17 year
olds those that are actually
experiencing so the younger the person
we what we're finding is that from a
complex safeguarding point of view we're
tending to get in a little bit earlier
um and it's not actually it's the young
people haven't got into the patn or or
aren't being exploited at that point but
we are have concerns so I don't know if
that offers you some
Assurance thank you thank you for your
comments I should have also said this
makes me really proud really really
proud thank you um councilor Park yeah
it's also um to say thank you as well um
one of the biggest issues as you'll know
with situations of abuse is the
silencing of survivors and this report
privileges Survivor voices so that's
really really profound and really good
to see and the um other point that you
focused on was um about the work that
you're doing on prevention or hoping to
do on prevention just wanted to ask if
shine services are working with the
virtual schools as well is there
something that's been fantastic thank
you so just for clarity the model like I
say that the shine service Works to is
that there is a dedicated shine worker
where we think there is a evidence to
suggest somebody might be at risk of
exploitation or somebody is being
exploited there will be a social worker
that sits in the other social work teams
and that brings in if it's somebody that
is cared for all of the resources and
the support of the virtual school and we
we do work really closely with our
schools because whilst Tracy is
absolutely right in terms of saying
actually the younger cohort are those
that we think might get drawn into
exploitation there might be indicators
of risk what we do know nationally and
what we do know locally is that actually
the age profile is lowering and that's
really a a worrying Trend so it's really
important that we do have those
prevention conversations not just in
terms of early identification but
thinking almostly Unthinkable about how
young consumed he be to to get embroiled
in situations of
harm could I just add we we do have a
member of the virtual school who sits on
the shine panel so they uh um provide us
some information and share their views
in terms of any referrals reviews or
closures of young people and we have um
a dedicated um School Champion within
the Shine Service as well who attends um
the virtual school meetings to talk
about any young people who um are not in
education training or employment um and
I also attend the corporate parenting
board so I would feed in if there are
any specific issues with regard to care
for
children questions
thank you for the report it's an
excellent report um I'm really proud of
what what work we're doing
we
with yeah thank
you welcome to you're welcome to stay or
you want to go home and get your dinner
you're
more thanks and it's it's nice to see
you and I hope you'll come and see us
again we're not that scary
[Music]
really okay
so um going to move on to item seven
which is the Healthy Start report and
we've got Helen and Kate I believe yeah
hi yes thank you so I'm Helen I'm
director of Public Health at Trafford
I'm just going to do an introduction so
I don't want to steal Kate Thunder
because she's um kind of LED this agenda
item but I just wanted to say that um we
are shaping our approach to health
inequalities in Trafford at the moment
we're looking at kind of moving it from
that conceptual into that real practical
action focused work and there's lots of
brilliant work already going on but it's
just about kind of pulling it together
and coordinating it and knowing um
exactly where we need to Target so as a
public health Team we work very closely
with Jill and colleagues we're committed
to addressing Health inequalities
particularly thinking about giving our
children the best start in life we work
through the health and well-being board
and also um through the locality board
as well a strong focus on the wider
determinance so the papers that you've
received this evening around attendance
around exploitation all link very much
into um Health inequalities and and the
impact that the wider determinants have
on our children so when we think about
children and inequalities around obesity
for example a lot of those drivers um
affecting those children will be very
similar to those drivers that affect
those children who've been exploited or
who are who are likely to end up in um
situations of violence as well so very
much kind of um thinking about that
population approach there so we're in
the process at the moment of developing
a partnership approach to reducing
Health inequalities which will be
complementary to the greater Manchester
um far health for all approach so we are
um going to stand a partnership called
far Health in Trafford where we'll be
collecting together all the activity um
around health and equality so we have
kind of that insight and coordination
for the work as well um and that will
mean that we you know have a really
strong kind of shared narrative around
how we are improving and reducing the
impact of Health inequalities across the
life course because I think as Jill will
tell us children live in families so we
can't can't think about children's
inequalities without really thinking
about uh their families their
grandparents and their carers as well so
I'm going to hand over to Kate um and
just to introduce Kate Kate's only been
with us a couple of months she's our
brand new Public Health consultant and
she's leading our children and young
people's portfolio so thanks Kate thanks
Helen thanks everyone um okay so firstly
to to you know thank you for the item
being brought to the agenda really it's
been a a useful exercise for us uh as
well as hopefully giving you um an
overview to start with in terms of this
broad question um it is necessarily uh
an overview of a uh very wide ranging um
agenda then there will be things that
are missing from this that we could look
into obviously the intention uh with the
approach that I've taken is to give you
a flavor of some of the things that are
um kind of key findings and um activity
as you've asked for in the title uh to
address some of those inequalities we
know about um but we can come back with
far more information on any of the areas
that you want more detail on of course
um and so forgive me if I can't answer
all of the questions on some of the
detailed areas because this covers work
which um we've taken a kind of Public
Health view on but certainly involves
input from colleagues and work being led
by colleagues in children's services
particularly but across the council and
and within the ICB and the health
partners of course um so the drivers of
health and therefore Health inequalities
are of course complex as we've Helen's
alluded to and others have touched on uh
today um the figure uh the figure at
figure one in the paper gives you a a
sense of that which taken from the
greater Manchester Fair of Health for
all uh document uh which is relatively
new um I've tried to structure the paper
in a way that uh is helpful and um I
found it helpful recently to refer to a
kind of simplified uh model that looks
at that that um considers the social or
wider determinance of Health sometimes
refer to that Helen's uh touched on so
um that include of course children's
experience of Education that we've
covered in some detail today um uh
poverty and the finances available to
families um housing and things like that
um that that those things then determine
the way that the opportunities people
have to uh live healthily so the the
empowerment that people have or
otherwise um bar to to choosing if you
like or to living a healthy lifestyle um
and then those uh behaviors that people
and the way that people live their lives
in terms of things like smoking obesity
you know eating uh alcohol impact on
their um acute and if you like clinical
Health kind of needs and the use of
services but actually you need to work
at all those levels in order to impact
on health inequalities um and different
partners around the system will be
playing more of a role uh or less of a
role in some of those this paper partly
in an effort to keep it uh manageable
for myself and for you focuses on the um
the second and third layer of those so
the kind of Public Health if you like
and behavioral factors and the health
and uh care services that are available
and the inequalities in the experience
or outcomes from those um rather than uh
but it recognizes sorry this the
importance of the social determins and
context of our fam's uh lives and the uh
there's a wealth of work going on in
those areas of course including strategy
development and uh you know the results
of the poverty truth commission and so
on um and I suppose our uh role um with
yourselves is the championing of
children's and families needs uh within
that and an eye on inequalities within
that wider work this paper doesn't go
into detail on those aspects I hope
that's okay um uh
so as well as the kind of those three uh
broad brush areas it starts with a focus
on some of the core um uh some of the
kind of groups of people that are not
covered if you just take a uh
geographical or a um deprivation based
uh look at inequalities which is what we
do tend to do and it is poverty being
one of you know being really the single
uh most uh clear driver of uh health of
inequalities in general but there are
groups uh some of whom we have talked
about in detail today who um will be
missed if you just look at that uh that
alone and you can obviously look at lots
of different groups who experience
poorer Health uh compared to the average
I've drawn attention to some in there
who I think are a priority for us at the
moment um but there there will be others
and welcome to to obviously we can
discuss those and bring back more
information on the specific approaches
the key with those groups of course is
to have a deliberate focus on them as
we've heard is happening for children
for example looked after children with
send or children involved in um criminal
criminality or violence or exploitation
um otherwise there is a risk of some
kind of broad brush approaches of
widening inequalities which is kind of
the theme so the there's um some of the
key figures uh in terms of uh what the
inequalities look like are covered in
that summary um uh the action then to
deal with some of those is covered in
more detail in the report I'll just draw
your attention to a couple of them
although uh know you'll have read it um
so there's a significant focus in the
paper on the um early years and
particularly the start for Life period
which is the conception to Age Two um uh
where we are are um working with
colleagues in children's services and
Zoe is here working closely with us and
leading on a lot of that um but also
with our partners across the system
maternity uh Health visitors um and our
vent sector partners for example to um
translate the evidence base that is
quite clear about the importance of
those years and to um improve the
connection between our services and make
that period a positive experience for
families in the whole and using
community to support families to get
that best start in life um uh there's
some improvements that we've seen and
some really positive news around uh the
good level of development um and some of
those early developmental measures uh in
the reviews that go on um which uh which
are covered there so um for the first
time in October 2023 data there's no
area in the west of Trafford now below
average for communication language or
physical development which had been uh a
real real priority Target and credit to
uh lots of work that Z and colleagues
have have have led there um and there
are General improvements across Trafford
and in some of our uh uh priority kind
of cohorts um so that's really positive
um and an ongoing Focus um one of the
other areas I wanted to draw your
attention to because it is new uh data
um and a POS a really helpful finding
and interesting finding for us um is the
uh data from the national child
measurement program which uh uh is the
surveillance of healthy weight in
children uh that's uh done at reception
age and again at year six and the uh
most recent data for
2223 uh shows that for reception pupils
uh so age four to five um the
inequalities in uh excess weight uh and
in um so that's both in terms of
overweight and um uh obesity um the
higher level of obesity have been the
inequality has effectively been
eliminated since 20178 so we've really
reduced that gradient of the difference
between the most and least deprived
children in Trafford when you look at
them into in the deprivation uh
quintiles and um that's really positive
because we haven't just done that by
seeing an increase uh in the um in the
most deprived sorry in the least
deprived groups getting uh higher rate
of of obesity we've reduced it in those
uh groups who are more deprived so
that's really positive however um the
data also shows that the year six uh um
for year six pupils that gradient is
still present and possibly uh increasing
now so there's a real Focus for us now
in terms of that cohort between
reception and year six um and there's
some examples in the paper including
work on uh physical activity uh as well
as um the healthy weight Steering group
looking at more population measures such
as around school school food advertising
um and things like that that we hope uh
will make a real difference
um there's a lot of information uh in
the some information in the report about
uh mental health and emotional
well-being which I know will be uh is a
concern for all of us um national and
local uh intelligence suggesting uh
increased uh need and complexity for
children um and we've touched on some of
those things uh those the way that
that's displaying itself today um and
there's there's some information in the
report about some of the services and
response that's going on uh across
Trafford to support those young people
um the focus obviously of on
inequalities uh in this report um so
we're looking at the things that are
targeted uh for um young people in our
most deprived areas particularly and
some of those cohorts we've talked about
um and one of the things that we are
looking at doing with um uh Manchester
Foundation trust and the local um
provider organizations is to think about
how the what the pattern is of
inequalities in terms of our waiting
lists and our um access to Serv serves
because nationally we know from research
that um there tend to be unexpected
inequalities in those kind of
experiences so that's an important bit
of intelligence that we need to um
gather um just see what else I was going
to draw your attention to
um there's some uh again kind of very
recent uh information so that's I'll use
that to draw your attention to it but
the subsection in there on immunizations
uh of course and and um we know that
since covid the rate of immunizations
has decreased nationally as well as
locally for a range of uh of vacines
particularly childhood vaccinations um
and that that uh we've always had uh
inequalities in the uptake of
immunizations we're doing some targeted
work uh that's uh halfway through
working through the north uh practices
the GP practices in the north to um
working with a V sector provider to
Target families with children under five
to have a community conversation um and
really understand the barriers for them
and why they may not have uh looked in
and helped to lay any concerns uh record
what their reasons are Etc and to work
with the GPS there to and the staff in
the practice more generally because the
receptionists can be important of course
and other stuff um to um book book
patients in and to increase that uptake
amongst those targeted cohorts
particularly some of our ethnic minority
populations um which appears to be uh
having good results so far um even small
increases in the uptake of the MMR in
that cohort um will make a big
difference because there's obviously
residual effects on the family and
Community um so yeah there's a lot in
there obviously can't Jo I won't go into
detail on on all of it but happy to
answer any questions and just to
summarize I suppose the Strategic
actions which are um covered at the end
there and I hope um you you know get out
get your support on really um so the as
I say the ongoing advocacy for children
in people and the inequalities uh as a
deliberate Focus uh in The Wider
determinance work that is ongoing and
that you'll you'll be involved in um uh
we want to Advocate we need to advocate
for better data recording of protective
characteristics particularly um and
Analysis by deprivation uh uh and by by
kind of geography um which is not yet at
the standard that we'd like across the
board and will help us with this kind of
analysis going forward um and we've got
focus on improving information uh for
families and young people we know that
some of the issues uh in terms of
experience and access um will be to do
with uh confidence uh information um and
knowing where to go in the system and so
a will focus on improving the um uh
resources that are available for
families both in terms of knowing who to
call but also um better information for
self-care and supporting your own
children which um we know families want
to do um
and I think that's probably it for now
obviously welcome any questions and then
and U we've referred in the um
recommendations or next steps to the
support that we'd welcome from you for
the programs that Helen's referred to in
terms of standing up the fair health for
Trafford uh group and some of the
engagement um mechanisms feeding into
all of this work which we I answered in
the question at the beginning but we'll
send out in a written response to add to
the paper thank you very much Kate for
the report um does anybody have any
questions councelor
Enis thank you and really really welcome
this report especially um the lines
about the broomwood moving partnership
which is really really important in in
timley central Ward but also what's
important I think is that we make full
use of the brimwood community center and
as a local Hub and the Char local
charities and Community groups that
support that area I think you'll find
that there's a real desire in broom to
support this strategy and you'll get a
lot uh an awful lot of community buying
there can I make just a point though
about um mobile gambling because I'd
like to see more of a focus on that um I
think it it can be too easily overlooked
and I think especially its impact on
young men the way that young men in
particular marketed to is a real problem
and I I see it as as an impact in
communities that are more deprived so I
wonder if you think there's more scope
for us to to work in that area
specifically um so first I'll go in
reverse order if that's okay um really
welcome your comment about gambling um
so we've got a new uh Trafford alcohol
substance misuse and gambling
partnership it's not a good acronym so
I'm not going to say it um but that I
chair and has uh met three times now I
think possibly four actually um with um
we had the first meeting and actually
again this time a real focus on gambling
um because as you say once when you um
when you bring up an item so we had a
lived experience input at one of the
meetings and it uh dominated the meeting
for the rest of the time really because
there was so much interest concern um
other experience in the room from
Partners who either had or hadn't really
thought about the issue but then could
see the benefits of for them of linking
up better on on it so we are um we've
supported with the greater Manchester uh
kind of series of strategies and
approaches that um include working with
um chap to one who are kind of preferred
um provider if you like but free because
they are free from uh gambling industry
uh involvement which is quite a diff is
a big diff challenge around this agenda
um and they have offered training which
we've rolled out through that
partnership and and Beyond uh networks
but it's fairly Limited at the moment
because it's GM commission um and
actually because the organization
themselves based on uh working with
people with lived experience and a
relatively small um uh neish
organization that they can't offer as
much as we probably could now um feel so
we have feedback that we would be
interested and we've got Partners who
are really interested in more uh work on
gambling um the there's been various
discussions about the different cohorts
who are particularly affected um and how
hidden the harm can be um so colleagues
from safeguarding um and um wider
children services as well as others who
work with young people such as early
break are part of that partnership and
have had the discussion about how to
embed the quest asking the question
about gambling when they're having
conversations about context of young
people's lives and and risks because it
isn't routinely asked by a lot of um
partners and services and support um in
terms of kind of um campaigns um there
was uh a relatively small scale I would
say but GM Le campaign about the odds
are they win um which was um which was a
talk part of that but I think you're
right that there's um something about
young people and the early intervention
opportunities that we um that we we need
to feedback to GM and I can get more
information on what's the plans are and
um sort of um opportunities around that
welcome the the focus thank you I'm
sorry chair if I push on the broomwood
point as
well so just on broomwood absolutely
recognize that um there needs to be
focus on Bloom but I think it's a really
interesting part of the south in that
it's often forgotten about because it is
within the South if that makes sense
obvious you know there's a um
misconception isn't there and I reckon
I'm just looking at Karen but during the
pandemic i' would have to say the
primary school in broomwood was
brilliant the engagement and the support
that they gave us during the pandemic
was second to n she was brilliant head
teacher but um in terms of the
neighborhood program that we're very
much engaged with um I know that George
develin voluntary sector and our um
Community officers down there down and
Adrian are working very much out in that
Community there to to gather insight and
to um support the implementation of the
neighborhood priorities into that
Community um councilor
s um yes thank you for this report so
much uh really crucial uh detail and uh
amount of uh statistics um including in
the um the section on sexual
reproductive Health uh which is why it
um rather stood out to me that one area
that's not reported on is um children
young people's access to uh gender
identity or gender Doria
Services um it's a field that's woefully
under resourced nationally um and has a
big toll on mental health and of course
all those other knock on effects we've
been talking about School
attendance school non attendance and all
of that uh but also it's an area that's
subject to Relentless uh hostile attacks
in the public sphere um so I suggest
that perhaps this is a particular
important uh extra field that uh we
could perhaps request and addendum to
the report we brought uh to the future
future meeting yeah yeah happy to do
that um welcome that and I believe there
are some developments um through um with
our Cam's partners that they've
mentioned that are in train so we'll get
some more information and think back
yeah thank you good point thank
you I mean we have had some some
incidents um that relate to a
safeguarding nature where um gender
identity was one of the factors not
necessarily the determining factor and
we have had some local and some Regional
conversations about what do we need to
do to think about one how we support and
equip our widest possible Workforce to
to have some of those conversations
obviously in in Trafford we do have some
Single Sex schools so that means that
actually thinking about some of those
issues becomes even more complex if it
can be even more complex in a in a
complex set of
circumstances we do have some Services
um like our youth service who are
actually going through the formal
accreditation in terms of um the the
rainbow flag and work with the proud
trust in recognition of some of the the
complexities but the need to be
sensitive to get under the skin and
really understand what that means for
our children and young
people that's really good to hear thank
you
Council thank you so my w lost to Bart
and straddles the M60 there's four
schools very close to the M60 and I have
lots of anecdotal evidence about the
increase in
asthma it's something that massively
concerns me um
I I did my first degree in Birmingham
around the time there was the research
about um lead in petrols causing or
contributing to learning disability in
children specifically around Spaghetti
Junction in
Birmingham what what concerns me about
asthma rates is absence of school um the
knock on impact of a child's Health by
being so close to a Motorway do you have
um better evidence than my own doal
evidence about asthma
rates in in spe specifically in Lost
talk and Barton Ward but in in our
schools in Trafford
thanks don't have it to hand but we can
look to see around Admissions and uh
Primary Care rates but what we I just
going to open my laptop then but I think
it'll take too long but what we also
have have is the air quality monitoring
of the particles along the roads because
we were asked a question about another
Community last week around some issues
that had been raised and and that
provides another layer of evidence for
us so what we will do councelor Proctor
is Kate and I will go away and just send
you some high level kind of detail about
that but really interesting question and
um it's a one of day core I was get the
wrong around plus five for children is
asthma as well so yeah we will comment
yeah I was just going to add to that
sorry um we've met uh just today with
the population Health Management lead
from the tlco um Trafford local Care
Organization who um uh is leading is
come from over from Manchester where
they have been leading his program he's
going to roll some work out in Trafford
um which is about doing um kind of hyper
local targeted work on core um priority
areas um so that you can do things in a
localized way but see the benefit in in
inequality that's that's at Trafford
wide that's the the program as they've
been doing it in Manchester and we asked
about whether there would be a
children's priority within that um
because they are taking the cour plus 5
as their approach so information is in
the paper on that um and um they suspect
they are uh Consulting and engaging with
people at the moment and need to do that
for Trafford more but they suspect that
Asma will the focus there so I think if
there is a local um interest and um
potential to do some kind of uh H
localized improvement work um we could
recommend that to them as well to look
into and that would be about tracking
that data and doing something and and
using the data to then see if that makes
a difference on an inequality
specifically so that's helpful I'll pass
that on that that's excellent there's a
local group breathe clean air who
regularly send me
particle data um around um I think it's
lostock
Road um as being particularly high and
particularly challenging
so yeah anything else to support that
will be great thank
you Council abort you have a
question thank you chair uh just wanted
to pick up on uh the item about dental
care in the five to nine year
olds there is mention obiously it's a
great concern that between five and N
there's a lot of dental decay and
uh the the focus seems to be on urgent
treatment as opposed to
prevention and there's nothing being
said about what's to be done or you know
how you going to tackle it in any way uh
so I'm just so looking obviously the
treatment the dentists will get paid for
so to speak but prevention is always a
little bit more difficult and yet preven
ition is the more important of course
with the fluoride uh Vish you're talking
about on this so is there anything that
can be done can picked up in terms of
being able to have an impact I mean it
gives thees the example of uh bucklo at
Marty uh which has got a particularly
high incident of the situation so uh um
just wanted to have your views as to
what you you know is there anything that
you can be are capable of doing about it
or looking at yeah thank you yeah thank
you um absolutely our um I suppose our
role in our in public health and in the
local Authority is to Champion and to
lead on activity that is about
preventing um all um uh poor O health
and and particularly targeting those
inequalities so um there is some
information in there as like I say can
get get more certainly on that because
that we've got some some programs of
work that we do commission and lead on
so we don't have uh um a mandate around
dental access for example which we know
is a national problem we do obviously
Advocate and Lobby around that um and we
uh we do have some role around um people
who cannot access uh dental care for
example but in terms of our children and
preventing that um that early oral um
ill health um we work closely with the
the health visiting uh team in
particular um and with um um Community
groups but we've got the uh and early
year settings um we've got the
toothbrush and toothpaste distribution
uh scheme and uh supervised
toothbrushing those are both
evidencebased programs uh that have been
um rolled out in various parts of
Greater Manchester and showed some
positive effects so we uh lead on those
in Trafford um and uh those are targeted
so that there is more um uh provision
for the children who are more most
likely to need that um that also
obviously feeds into work around uh
reduced uh sugar uh that I referred to
in terms of our more population
long-term efforts to reduce advertising
and to address uh sort of vending
machines in Leisure centers and that
kind of thing but in terms of specific
programs um we have got some yeah some
some stuff that we are leading on that's
evidence-based that we hope to address
address that thank you Council
Paul hi um so there's a concern for for
um under 18s consumption of alcohol
looks like because of the higher rates
of admissions relating to alcohol for
under eatings which is higher in traffic
than England so I do appreciate the
government's policy of stopping the
start and it's it's it's a welcome
policy and I do see here that
um uh Trafford school health has
delivered health promotion sessions on
risk and harms of vaping to
approximately 45 years six
classes and uh also
that you're coordinating with trafford's
response to consultation in partnership
with stakeholders through Trafford
tobacco Alliance in relation with uh
making more awareness uh in terms
of more awareness created for vaping and
stuff like that so C can we be um inform
about what steps you're taking in terms
of you know making kids more aware of
this so that we don't have such high
numbers thank
you yeah uh no problem yeah of course um
so vaping is uh obviously particularly
um high-profile uh issue at the moment
and we have had local concerns raised by
through the schools uh for example um
and through um our um school health
groups and through our young people's
groups actually and that's uh we were uh
working on um response to vaping with
those particular with the young people's
groups co-producing with us some
resources uh starting a year or so ago
so we were kind of try to be ahead of
the the game if you like in that sense
recognize that issue quite early but
it's ongoing and we think probably from
some of the um some of the data which
has a lot of carats around it there
isn't really a very robust easy to
interpret set of data on terms of
prevence of vaping specifically in young
people it's the kind of thing that is
difficult to ask young people about
because obviously they don't want to uh
admit to it necessarily um but from what
we we do know that we know yeah we think
it's probably increasing prevalence um
and so um we're designing as it says uh
as well as the resources that we
designed with young people last year um
we've now commissioned some additional
support through early break working with
school health Team to uh and working
with a task and finish group with some
of our schools uh Representatives as
well
um and uh testing this on designated
schools lead safeguarding lead and
others um to roll out a program that
includes webinars for parents and for
staff because there's there's still a
lot of misconceptions and
misunderstandings about um about vaping
and the risks and also the difficult
message about vaping being a good tool
for smokers adult smokers to quit uh
whilst also protecting you people from
the the harms um and from starting
vaping if they they're not smoking um so
with there's some uh webinars assemblies
and then drop in type sessions that are
being um developed and run by the um
early breaking school health working
together um which is something it's a a
newer um model to try and enhance that
capacity really around that issue um and
um in terms of
alcohol it is concerning and um we have
alcohol as one of our health and wellbe
board priorities I ities all age um for
children and for groups of um adults um
who we think are missing from uh formal
treatment some groups who are less
likely to want to access formal
treatment because they don't see that as
you know drug and alcohol treatment as
something that they need or that they
would fit into because there's certain
cohorts who who are less likely to be
there um so uh young people are one of
those groups and again we've put in some
additional um funding into our young
people's substance service early break
to specifically tackle alcohol in uh
young people their service users were
already um uh alcohol was very common um
for their group of young people so those
who are using other substances as well
but we do know that there's wider um
work that needs to be done to um with
young people so I think it's it's an
area for priority with under the new
Trafford alcohol substance misused
gambling partnership that I mentioned
earlier and we can bring um with they
doing A needs assessment uh to inform
the uh new uh vision and action plan so
we can share all of that with you um
when it's developed uh early next year
um which will be going to the health and
wellbe board and and obviously locality
board Etc as well and young people are
focused within that so I think there's
certainly more we can be doing but we
are aware of that um conscious of that
issue thank you very much um Kate thank
you oh sorry no that's fine uh so uh
because I see that uh these classes
about awareness were given to year six
so is that something that would be
restricted to only your six or will go
beyond because teenagers fall pre to
this quite often yeah good question
thank you sorry if it wasn't clear in
the reports and things are have
developed in the last l in the last week
or two um so the year six sessions um
were delivered um last year and this
year um including through the crucial
crew um setup which some of you may be
familiar with some that a lot of our
schools um take year year six pupils to
but also to work through others uh
sessions with the school health Team and
that was particularly through the school
nursing school health Team um the new um
work that's going on um to enhance that
if you like with early break working
with them um is going to be in high
schools um primarily and will um Target
probably year eight year nine on the
feedback of the school staff um in terms
of where where to target that resource
um and our school health and early break
both offer onetoone support as well of
course on referral from um schools or
parents and others um for any any age
thank you thank you thank you and thank
you for the report and thank you very
much for joining us um it's very
reassuring very positive um the work
that's being done so we do thank
you um to move on to item eight which is
an officer update I'm not aware of any
urgent updates from officers however
would just like to um make the committee
aware that um councilor Pro turd raised
um some concerns about the number of
sent tribun rules um so we have raised
this with um director of children
services and I understand Jill there's
some work going on in the background
already with this is don't know it's
yourself or Cara that's going to yeah I
can provide some responses to the the
questions that were raised if that's all
right um coun Proctor I think you were
asking for the data um as well um sorry
just let me get my specs on I can read
my not oh dear getting old um in terms
of the current position we've got 12
cases that have been lodged to tribunals
that's the current
position um over again currently we know
that three cases have reached agreement
prior to hearing um one parent withdrew
their case and wait eight are waiting to
be heard uh since 2021 again just a bit
of a brief update the council's position
was upheld twice and the parents
position
once um there is a more kind of we can
give a breakdown if you like of kind of
reasons for the the case being lodged
Etc if that will be helpful so we can we
can absolutely provide that I think in
terms of the I mean I don't know whether
you want to read your questions and
whether I or you you just want my
responses so shall I just yeah because
we've we've responded to each one if if
that's helpful for you so I think you
you asked a question around um
reassessments um so just for clarity um
we carry out a reassessment of need if
there has been if there is agreement
that that presenting need has changed
and we're normally aware of that either
just prior to or um upon the review of
any EHC plan the annual review if a
parent requests um a full EHC EHC needs
assessment then we'll go out to all
agencies as as we would um and those
that know the child will respond within
the time scale we don't force
reassessment um and we always work with
parental consent and
permission I think you then asked a
question around why we are um uh forcing
families to take us to tribunal when you
know um needs haven't changed Etc um
just to reassure you the decision to
appeal to tribunal is a parental
decision so it's not it's not not for us
we work really really hard to try and
resolve any disagreement uh before we
actually get to tribunal and that
includes holding meetings with families
uh and schools particularly when we've
made a decision either not to carry out
an needs assessment or or issue a plan
um and those are quite lengthy
discussions because it's it's also about
trying to reassure families that this is
the level of support that their child or
young person will receive in school and
we we have that as part of the
conversation um it also provides us with
some really good insight as well into
some of the concerns that families are
sharing and and why they wanted an ease
assessment or or a plan um parents can
request
mediation um I think we we're seeing
more and more of those mediation
meetings that's an independent mediator
um that the local authorities
commissioned um and again this is used
increasingly where families want to try
and get a solution before going to
tribunal so you know that's really
helpful as
well um in terms of how many send
families uh end up at the tribunal I've
shared that with you um again we try to
always Adar with law uh changes in
demand it is difficult because we know
we are making difficult decisions in in
challenging times for families um but um
our head of send and inclusion has been
more than happy to arrange a meeting
with you individually if that would be
helpful Council appr proor to just
explain sort of the you know the the
processes uh and and give you some of
the lived experiences if that would be
helpful thank you I think it would um my
concern my biggest concern is that
um I know of two families whove
repeatedly had to go to Tribunal take
Traer to tribunal and then win
um and and what they win is the right to
have the same level of support for their
child that the previous assessments had
shown and we've we've that's why I used
the word forced
because that's been four times the same
family has ended up in a tribunal case
and that bothers me greatly because
they're then awarded what they should
have been awarded at the beginning yet
we've made them go through this
horrendous
process when their child's needs haven't
changed I don't understand why we do
that as an
authority um I mean again I I would say
it's the parental right to go to
tribunal you know but I accept that you
know what you're saying is it's because
of a disagreement if be like uh in terms
of what what the council feel as um you
know the decision that's been made um
and again I think the meeting will be
helpful to to go through that there are
many reasons why families might take
might op for the tribunal it might be
disagreement over placement it might be
dis you know isn't just about need it's
also about placement provision um and
certain aspects it may be to do with
health as well um so I think every case
is an individual case it's it you you
know we completely agree it's it's not a
nice process and it's not one that we
you know we want our families to to
experience it's not one that we as a
local Authority um you know want to go
through either uh which is why the
meetings with families when we are
trying to seek a solution are so
important and actually have prevented
have prevented so many of these
situations as well um so you know but
we're always learning um but I think
Sally would be more than happy to set
aside some time at you know whenever
it's convenient for you to to discuss
this in in in full that s if I can just
come in with a couple of points Council
proor um you will be aware that we've
recently had our local area partnership
and I am emphasizing the partnership
word um send inspection we did get the
draft report this week it will be
published mid December um slightly later
than we'd anticipated because um the
lead inspector went on a holiday and
then they were late sending the the
draft report so we can't share with you
the details of of that um two things
that I would say is that the inspection
team from CQC and ofstead were really
clear that as a local Authority we knew
ourselves well they didn't disagree with
our self assessment and they said that
they saw some really committed
passionate people that were making a
difference to our children young people
and families that's not to negate that
there is more improvement work to do or
that when things are challenging or we
don't get things right it can be very
very difficult um we have a clear send
Improvement plan that's called our
Ambitions plan that will get updated
following the the publication or as we
get that that detail um we do have send
Improvement lead working with us at the
moment and we have really strengthened
our send partnership board um councilor
Carter sits on that board and one of the
things that we have agreed with our
parent carers because of the national
send and AP agenda is that we will
absolutely um have as one of our key
indicators the numbers of tribunals and
the reasons why um because you will be
very much aware the national agenda is
for greater inclusion we would all agree
with that as Karen's alluded to though
being able to meet need having placement
sufficiency is is critical in in that
regard and
and one of the things that we're really
mindful of is that as a partnership we
do have to come together to meet need so
it feels really important to understand
the unique complexities the unique
circumstances and what the offer of
support is we do know that we do need to
strengthen our annual review processes
um but that is about reflecting actually
has need changed has the plan made a
difference and what do we understand and
how we come together um so the lots for
us to think about lots of that we are
working on um but there is that
commitment
there thank you I think to add to that
as well um you may be aware we're part
of the uh change program which is about
testing the reforms proposed in the send
and AP Improvement plan um and I think
that the nature of those reforms will be
really helpful to us in terms of our
understanding and creating more rigor
and and getting that DHC process um just
by the very nature of the reform so I
think there's there's lots of
opportunities around that as
well thank you both if if we're getting
the um results of the inspection in
December could that possibly come to
scrutiny in um January for the January
meeting yeah be really helpful I think
okay so I'm not aware of any urgent
business um so with that I'd like to
call the meeting to a close thank you
all for attending it's nice to see some
new faces as well as the more familiar
ones I won't say old
faces yeah thank you everybody and
wishes sa J